Let's go next to Ryan from D.C.. Ryan from
D.C.
What's going on?
Hey, David.
I'm taking my call and a longtime listener.
My pleasure.
Thanks for taking the time.
My question is kind of more of a philosophical
one around, like some general political philosophy.
I'm with Texas kind of becoming more purple,
potentially even being blue by, say, 20, 30
ish, and then the potential of D.C. and Puerto
Rico gaining statehood, which would likely
go, you know, the Democratic route.
I think just by some of the general statistics
that we have currently, I'm wondering, you
know, what would be great about those scenarios
is that the right would have a very difficult
time winning the presidency ever again.
But I'm wondering more from a philosophical
standpoint, what you think it would look like
if the Democrats were dominating election
after election in some kind of a one party
system.
Do you think that the moderates and the and
the more progressive would kind of split within
the Democratic Party and create new parties?
What would that America look like?
That's very hard to predict.
And it's like I could make a prediction, but
we know that that, you know, it would essentially
be worthless because what do any of us really
know?
The one thing I think, though, is if indeed
Texas's population moves left such that Democrats
are really in contention nationally in Texas
or even win Texas.
My guess is that Texas Republicans would move
to the left and be back in contention.
It's sort of like, why do Massachusetts voters
who are quite left elect Republican governors
so frequently, well, they're not electing,
you know, Joni Ernst.
They're electing people like William Weld
and Charlie Baker and others.
Republicans in Massachusetts have moved left
in order to remain viable.
So my my instinct is that what you would see
in Texas, if it really starts to seem like
a like a national Republican could win, is
that the Texas Republican Party would start
coming to the left and they would remain viable.
And that would be good because we're we're
still moving to the left if that happens,
right?
Yeah, I think the Overton Window would kind
of continue to shift left.
And and I think that would actually still
be a net positive.
And, yes, you know, they would have to move
to the left just to survive.
I completely agree.
I think that's the most likely scenario.
You know, people think, oh, just Democrats
will win Texas from here until forever.
Well, OK.
I mean, at some point that could happen.
But you could also see Republicans re reinstate
their sort of 55 45 majority by just moving
a little bit to the left.
Brian.
That's great.
Yeah, was just something I was kind of thinking
about and wanted to kind of bounce it off,
you suggested we call David.
My pleasure.
All right.
Thank you so much.
Great to hear from
you